[Music]
you know him as the angry white male and
old joe biden but did you know that he's
also a comedian you wouldn't know it
just kidding give a big round of
applause for our dear friend tom salud
thank you
i love you guys
i love a big crowd with uncovered faces
good to see you
we're in a moment of extreme caution in
this country aren't we that's not the
way we grew up
we thought we were safe we probably
weren't
remember those rides in the family car
in the back seat no seat belts
seat belts highly optional in the 1970s
yeah you you know dad took a right you
just slide over to the left
take a left you slide back it worked
it worked
we were less safe we were less sensitive
in the 70s
if you wanted about the sensitivity
level of the 1970s look at the
advertising
look at the commercials we had the frito
bandito
the most politically incorrect spokesman
in the history of salted snacks
for those two young to remember the
frito bandito was a three and a half
foot tall mexican
thief
[Applause]
he would come in a town with guns
blazing steal your fritos eat them while
you watched
then he would lean against a tree pull
his sombrero over his eyes and take a
nap
they would never get away with that
today can you imagine the guy suggesting
that at the ad agency today
they'd be like uh okay your concept the
frito bandito
uh phil you don't work here anymore
you gotta go to hr right now
all the commercials were insensitive you
remember the uh that detergent how do
you keep my husband's shirts so clean
ancient chinese secret gong
really
some of them were violent
remember that a hawaiian punch
every commercial was the same there'd be
kids on the playground i am thirsty i
don't know where this hawaiian would
walk in and punch the kid directly in
the face
and it wasn't a fun little tap it was a
full-on he would clock the kid
he was an unconscious child on the
playground
everyone's celebrating yay hawaiian
punch
[Music]
timmy's in a coma
the jingles were politically incorrect
remember that the hot dogs arm or hot
dogs what kind of kids eat armor hot
dogs
fat kids yeah fat kids
that kids they listed all the children
of the world
start with the fat kids
was there a discussion about that
they're like should we start with the
fat kids definitely that's our customer
base
secure the fatties move on from there
fat kids skinny kids kids who climb on
rocks
it's an extremely specific demographic
there right
now
tough kids [ __ ] kids they said [ __ ]
kids
[Applause]
and they showed a [ __ ] kid
he's holding a hot dog balling his eyes
i don't want to be this disney good
well you're good at it crybaby
even kids with
chicken
chicken box
wow
that's appetizing
even kids with chicken pox look i i did
not go to copywriting school but i'm
pretty sure rule number one is don't
associate your product with a
communicable
disease you guys are great thank you so
much
[Music]
everyone